Traduttore: Giulia Claudi
Revisore: Maria Pericleous
Sembra un po' il ritmo
del mio battito cardiaco adesso.
Il viaggio di oggi inizia da qui,
l'essere umano si forma
e già riesce a percepire luce e suono.
Meglio ancora, riesce a percepire
espressioni emozionali di luce e suono.
Questo perché la natura è meravigliosa,
utilizza dei linguaggi che ci permettono
di comunicare ancora prima della parola,
ancora prima del gesto.
La natura è fatta di luce e suono
e li distribuisce sapientemente,
in grande armonia.
Luce e suono sono i linguaggi
che la natura utilizza
per raccontare la sua bellezza,
per farcela conoscere,
per farcela apprezzare,
così da condividerla e poter preservarla.
Conoscere e condividere la bellezza
aiuta a generarne di nuova,
aiuta a mantenere viva quella che abbiamo
tutta intorno a noi e dentro di noi
nella parte più profonda
del nostro essere umano.
Bene, più che un punto di partenza
è un punto d'arrivo
nel senso che durante il mio percorso
sono arrivato a questa consapevolezza
attraverso svariate esperienze
e ho avuto la fortuna fin da piccolo
di conoscere quelle che comunemente
chiamiamo le varie forme d'arte:
la danza, la pittura, la musica.
Ricordo degli episodi
in cui la mia insegnante di pianoforte
cercava di insegnarmi in tutti i modi
il sistema dodecafonico e le scale
e io sentivo la musica
e non volevo far altro che suonare
e alla stessa maniera
i miei zii fin dall'inizio
hanno cercato di insegnarmi
l'utilizzo dei materiali
nelle varie tecniche pittoriche:
la teoria del colore.
Io non vedevo l'ora
di avere in mano i pennelli
per imbrattare tutto quello che trovavo.
Sapete, i bambini hanno una percezione
molto più estesa rispetto agli adulti,
hanno la visione nitida
di quello che li circonda
e lo percepiscono senza costruzioni
e quindi ogni luce, suono,
sono degli stimoli
e io fondamentalmente
facevo quello che mi piaceva.
Poi man mano, crescendo,
ho acquisito delle capacità
ho migliorato la tecnica,
e forse a un certo punto ho cercato
quasi più di diventare bravo
piuttosto che sentire.
Cercavo forse una dimostrazione
delle mie capacità,
con me stesso e nei confronti degli altri
e piano piano mi sono trovato
da solo, nel buio, in silenzio.
Avevo perso la luce e il suono.
E non era un problema di bollette,
semplicemente ero più concentrato
a cercare di migliorare una tecnica
piuttosto che utilizzare le mie capacità
per raccontare i miei pensieri.
Tutto attorno a me era stato oscurato
e il mio confronto con la realtà
era un semplice confronto superficiale.
Ho viaggiato, e viaggiando
ho ricominciato a sentire i suoni
dei luoghi e delle diverse culture
e ho ricominciato a vedere i colori
e ho ricominciato ad apprezzare il sorriso
delle persone che incontravo
e piano piano ho ricominciato a sentirmi
parte di questa grande armonia.
Finalmente avevo ricominciato
a percepire la bellezza.
Ogni luogo, ogni situazione
avevano un senso,
ogni colore e suono
erano uno stimolo per emozionarmi
e allora ho ripreso con forza
questa espressione artistica
che avevo acquisito
e ho dato a loro
un ruolo fondamentale:
provare a raccontare
tutta questa bellezza.
Nella storia ci sono stati
grandi artisti, grandi uomini,
che hanno investito tutta la loro vita
per cercare di raccontare la bellezza.
Chi ci è andato veramente vicino,
chi l'ha sfiorata, chi si è perso
nell'immensità di un tramonto
e chi nella profondità di un'emozione.
Ma com'è possibile raccontare
qualcosa di così grande?
Provate a pensare a un tramonto,
è una cosa talmente grande e infinita
che è difficile riuscire a raccontarla.
E come si può raccontare
la felicità in un sorriso
e come si può riuscire a farla percepire.
Dovevo trovare un modo
e ho guardato indietro ancora una volta
e ho pensato a come fanno i bambini
quando vogliono raccontarci qualcosa,
ci prendono per mano.
Allora ho preso in mano luce,
suono, musica e colore
e li ho uniti in un'esperienza emozionale
da condividere con voi.
È andata così.
(Video: Rumore di passi)
(Pianoforte)
(Musica)
(Fine musica)
(Applausi)
Non volevo un applauso per questo,
nel senso che questo
non è un elogio all'artista
per me è un elogio alla luce e al suono,
perché io credo che vivere
un'esperienza artistica
aiuti a migliorare
la percezione della bellezza.
Vedo e credo fermamente
che l'arte sia uno strumento
che aiuta a migliorare
la percezione della bellezza
così se noi avremo più percezione
della bellezza, riusciremo a condividerla,
riusciremo a generarne di nuova
e a preservare quella che abbiamo.
E quindi credo che dobbiamo
riappropriarci di questa capacità
e riappropriarci
della bellezza che abbiamo
così, come scriveva Dostoevskij:
"La bellezza salverà il mondo."
(Applausi)